♪ ♪
>> Sean: TROUBLING
DEVELOPMENTS TONIGHT SURROUNDING
CONGRESSWOMAN OMAR AMID NEW
REVELATIONS ABOUT SWAMPY
CAMPAIGN SPENDING PRACTICES.
HERE TO EXPLAIN MORE, CHIEF
BREAKING NEWS CORRESPONDENT
TRACE GALLAGHER.
>> WHEN CONGRESSWOMAN ILHAN OMAR
WAS ACCUSED OF HAVING AN AFFAIR
WITH A POLITICAL CONSULTANT,
OMAR VEHEMENTLY DENIED IT.
NOW SHE AND MY NET ARE MARRIED
AND THAT NEAR PROCESS OMAR
CONTINUOUS FUNNELING MONEY TO
HER NEW HUSBAND’S POLITICAL
CONSULTING FIRM.
RECORDS SHOW THAT SINCE 2018
OMAR HAS PAID MORE THAN $878,000
INCLUDING $189,000 JUST A FEW
MONTHS AGO.
THE FEDERAL ELECTION COMMISSION
ALLOWS LAWMAKERS TO HIRE THEIR
SPOUSE BUT POLITICAL EXPERTS AND
ETHICS LAWYERS CALL IT POLITICAL
CRONYISM AT ITS FINEST.
ILHAN OMAR ISN’T JUST TIM
MYNETT’S NEW WIFE.
SHE IS HIS FIRM’S BIGGEST
CUSTOMER AND AT ONE POINT, ONE
IN EVERY THREE OF ILHAN OMAR’S